o buongiorno ben trovati a una nuova
puntata del blog ma la puntata di oggi è
iniziata molto molto tardi perché con
l'attività del blog ma stiamo veramente
ogni giorno lavorando e col fatto che
cerchiamo anche l'ufficio insomma col
fatto che ci stanno un pochino di cose
che bollono in pentola
sto seguendo anche il progetto bit che
per chi non lo sapesse è in saldo per
tutto dicembre e l'osso che non ci credo
nemmeno io al 50 per cento
insomma sono riuscito a partire
solamente in cui no 105 50 per cento
dicevo sono riuscito a partire solamente
adesso quindi l'unica cosa che posso
dirvi è notte
parlando con un videogioco no sì sto
parlando con tre persone nel videogioco
fortunate videogiochi stanno rovinando
le persone prima gianmarco con lui cioè
le persone si chiudono troppo che i
videogiochi
leggete un libro fate come enrico sto
leggendo tra vari ha conquistati tutto
quanto una giornata fuori delle coccole
[Musica]
cosa fare dove andare da zia gas
ogni volta che arriva dicembre noi
abbiamo questa usanza di beccarci sempre
di più in famiglia lo facciamo sempre
durante l'anno ma durante il periodo
natalizio ci vediamo spessissimo culto
di aggredirlo guarda guarda come
aggredisce la camera oggi cerchiamo di
prendere un pochino più di views più
corto giugno fratello 10 in versilia
addominale e cerca di essere semplici
fratellini ma com'è possibile che tu è
la stessa genetica di galan sotto natale
si può fare di più
gabriele tue acceso quella luce per
avere le aree e uscite in che senza una
sorpresa nei giovani abbiamo pensato a
una sorpresa del tè fidati tutti
no io non mi sono immaginato di te
gianmarco messa insieme l'occhio di noi
singolarmente che da solo è no
gianmarco da solo no niente
avete pensato a un attività armata roba
da fare se ci mettiamo un pochino di
acqua di sudore finto sudore finto super
evento mai news news sale cos'era
tramite in realtà credo che fosse un
profumo di sette anni fa che diventa
tonino de vivo gare no sisto chiudiamo
contenuto vorremmo vedere come si fa la
partita ma non è per cattiveria solo
serio ho bevuto un litro di latte con
mezzo pacco di stima ma pensa quindi che
bello ma vomito
mi sento tranquillo in questa zona
ma sono questo e non venga detto che
guillermo non è a tecnico e atletico
vite parallele vita limite a pensare se
invece non pensare questa semplice
giusto pensare ai ti devo mettere male
aspetta pineto per concentrare il mini
queste gianluigi rimetterò il nino
chiamato anche minimi pericolo o
madonnina santa permetto quindi ti
guarda io se casco sul mezzo giro è ma
se giro il casco su non ci mette minir
ok ok a quattro zampe supply successivo
andiamo a casa di gianni sono arrivati a
casi gian marco ciao
e già da eliminare questa scena io gli
ho detto che abbiamo preparato una
sorpresa azione ingressi non sa di che
si tratta ma ha detto mi piacerà molto
vedremo chi non ha capito me l'ha detto
enrico vi diamo qualche qualche pillola
idea è un qualcosa che trasmette
emozioni emozioni forti
amore odio son ben odio di trani e
dentro ci sono pezzi di fa l'azienda che
io e le pizzette poi è arrivata l'ora
della sorpresa vaio
no no vediamoli station si sa dobbiamo
giocare ma dobbiamo giocare alla
playstation in collettivo di elmo devo
nora cazzo vuole che giochi a residente
il pan giochiamo tutti insieme davanti
stampa ha fatto pure frank se volete
vederlo andati sul canale di frank
matano lui l'ha fatto questo gameplay
non lo farò nemmeno nemmeno se mi pagate
beh non solo non vuole stare lascia fare
guglielmo casa dolce casa
era vendicato del giorno con a casa
dolce casa bergamo ma guarda questo che
ha fatto e ha fatto partire
questo è un bastardo sappi che ti amo in
italia meno che molti ti manca mai ma
scusi ma perché non mangiarla saranno
cazzi loro
lei non è molto a lei e p vorrei che la
ragione a roma ma è ovvio che ti
sapendone il culo a presente con i costi
per non venire mai lo sonora greco si
vabbè già cominciati ufficialmente
specchietti la ferrara è normale che si
inquadrava pronti a sferrare gli anni
proprio io già lo sterrato dall'inizio
va bene
arriva ad offrirlo ma scusa cosa che
adesso siete renato grande un ragazzino
mi attira i normali io mi aspetto ne
sempre appena cattivo ore settimanali
senti senti c'è un rumore strano è ora
dico batman ragazza che totti okaka
ragazzi questo è uno scenario di casa
quando ti devi accovacciati si
accovaccia quando hai camminato tutto
sta facendo di me ricorda la vigna dopo
due meriti pole dance oddio soccorrendo
nasale vai vai bravo stanno benissimo
hai visto ragazzi ho paura con tutto che
ho visto pezzi che barriere l'architetto
di questa casa scusa o ma che si sa
pochissimo pazzi ok apri questa volta
sbaglia la vita che casa ed un ok ok
allora a casa mia a casa mi ha lasciata
a casa mia che ha lasciato dove è stata
tralasciata che funziona a microonde
vidic e lasciato dentro questa prima
puntata di cucina punta alla porta male
sono io a casa mia che bella kasami
anche bella casa mia mamma che ridere
questo gioco di schietta mischia per
uccidermi ma mi interessa hanno velocità
perché quello che si sa bene chi ci
osserva perché si muove perché
un'altalena vabbè c'è po di vento dai ma
di non essere si muovono devono essere
le piccole mamma mia ragazzi che
albatros e così se questo è riuscito e
malefica questa casa è un fenomeno ma
qui si buttano spazio al duo invece no
non l'ho visto ciao mette riguardarlo
che scompare di matera ha che ti
attaccano perché papi dentro al camino
rincoglionito ha messo un gene un patto
di non capire come è fatto vanto aprire
un passaggio segreto quello di alzarsi
qualcuno lui nel senza culo appare voli
che seccano e non sono contro alla ma
sono pronto volontà
ok va bene è veloce però dall'altro la
prego torna a vedersi ma scusami le
ascelle
eccolo vabbè che vedete sopra mater e
lui senza muro
il video di frank si ferma qui quindi
adesso non so cosa succede qua c'è
questa cosa che è basso e questo nota
siate si apre cosa stavo per quello che
ha fatto veloci insomma non ci sei non
ti occhi mondi usa anche io le spese non
sono stati così paurosi a coro coro chor
vorrei che casa tua senza intera dove
dicembre andrè ti stiamo cercando
ecco nostri amici al muro è uno zombie
non la lascia dentro infatti istigati lo
sai che sembra che l lips rosy bindi
dato tanto è un mostro è il mostro ha
mostrato ancora eccola eccola qualcuno
se vi va non sono io non ho mai fatto
pur i boccoli e criminale arrivando
proprio dobbiamo andarci
a nascondersi nel sole donne amano come
sta parlando devo dire una cosa invidio
sembrava vincere 77 la classica proprio
che su instagram davvero guarda e passa
guarda video ecco il momento mano sulla
spalla subito infatti vedere comprensivo
non morti e adesso le regole ma l'amore
ti sei distratto un attimo quando a fine
giornata di si è detto ciò che questa
dal 38 si ok ma robert adesso non
abbiamo
ciao mamma
tanto lo prende la soluzione riferimento
nascondi entra la squarda league ma
perché guardi dove non lo guarda
basta ragazza ma ce la faccio a dirlo
non ce la faccio più adesso siamo
arrivati al momento clou bari prende
appunto come la tenda della finestra c'è
un cattivo c'è un cattivo ne approfitta
ok fan
combatti quando torna indietro
[Applauso]
aspettiamo
va bene una corazza
madonna
ma che vuol dire ridurre tutto questo lo
sto facendo io sapendo che sembrano
legati la gola ti giuro che non ti va
non ce n'è no è tornata nella presa
riesco sistemato dentro il mio corpo
[Musica]
oppure scusa uccidi la sola brava ok del
carlo grante il coltello e non conta
lucilla usa la soluzione ora si è posto
la lascia
come si fa adesso va meglio
[Risate]
[Applauso]
secondo gabriele dove un secondo zio di
partiti sono coloro che temono un
effetto non ci penso proprio fine fino a
23 i soldi che quello attacca risponde
un operatore makowski 6
e che cazzo succede
la città di bolca io non accettava tra
station
hai visto che sorpresona io ringrazio ci
sto qua scoppia mi scoppia il corpo
scoppia misura questo penso che abbia mi
scoppia come sta studiando questa
puntata finisce così io non so come
ritrovare il sacro il tour barbetta però
dobbiamo salvare
tutto anche senso è quella sua partita
perché continueremo cazzoni de sio noi
vogliamo creare a 100.000 a 300.000
laiche per il secondo episodio
io comunque vorrei solamente dire che il
problema che ho avuto con le ha
accettate e cose così contro lo zombie è
che io non capivo la differenza tra le 2
e le due non perché sono una pippa
poi l'ho capita e non sono stato
comunque bravo ma inizialmente quello
dei prof